XIAO-JING WANG: So
it's really a pleasure
to be here to attend
the inauguration
of this new Integrative
Computational Science Center.
Of course, MIT is a special
place in this field.
I thought I would mention that
Norbert Wiener pioneered what's
called Cybernetics here at MIT.
And this year is also
the 40th anniversary
of the publication
by David Marr,
the book called Vision, which
is still very much influencing
neuroscience and
cognitive science.
If you're familiar
with David Marr's work,
you probably mostly
remember, especially
younger people,
that he was really
a pioneer in computational
cognitive science,
mostly from computational
perspective.
But maybe it's good
to mention that he
has deep roots in neurobiology.
When he was an
graduate student, he
published this series of three
papers, really seminal papers,
modeled theories of
hippocampus, cerebellum,
and neocortex, based on
anatomy, based on circuits.
Unfortunately, he passed
away at the young age of 35.
As Francis Crick, who knew him,
stated, had he lived longer,
he would have moved to
a synthesis of those two
approaches.
So perhaps, today,
we can together
start to think about how
we can help to realize
that vision of a synthesis.
So of course, today,
we're living in an era
where AI pervades all
aspects of society.
Just to mention that
although today's systems are
tremendously successful in
solving certain problems better
than humans, you
could say that if it's
purely fit for the
architecture, then
when there's no external
input, the system
is essentially silent.
It doesn't do anything.
So in that sense, you could
say that this type of systems
don't really have a mental life.
By contrast, thinking,
reasoning, planning--
somehow, this went away.
This microphone stopped working.
Oh, maybe Michael,
he did something.
AUDIENCE: We need
the last [INAUDIBLE]..
XIAO-JING WANG: But
this stopped working.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, they
turned that off.
Yeah?
XIAO-JING WANG: Oh, you
want me to use this now?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
XIAO-JING WANG: OK.
Oh, great.
OK, sure.
That's good.
That solves the problem.
Either way.
Good.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
AUDIENCE: Can you turn
them down just a little?
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
XIAO-JING WANG: No problem.
No, this is great.
Yeah.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
AUDIENCE: This is [INAUDIBLE]
is through the technology.
XIAO-JING WANG: [LAUGHS]
Well, I just hope that Robert
will give me five more minutes.
So I was saying that reasoning,
thinking, planning, feeling
something from your fond memory,
essentially, internal processes
that are really not
enslaved to the environment.
And so those processes depend
on some brain structures,
especially what's called
the prefrontal cortex.
So maybe a challenge
for us is to think
about building a theory of
deep, recurrent neural networks
that are capable of this more
kind of internally driven
processes important
for mental life.
So if you try to think
into the future what kind
of measure of success for such
a model we could think about,
I will just mention one thing,
repeating what I just said.
Basically, a machine with
human-like intelligence
should, in principle, without
any external stimulation,
have something like
reasoning, using logic,
maybe creating something new,
and perhaps, even emotional
feelings out of memory.
So I'm going to tell
you a bit about how
we start to think about
this type of internally
driven processes.
First, a little bit of summary
about the micro circuits
that we have been
thinking about, and then,
spend more time, as
Robert mentioned,
our recent work building
multi-regional, large-scale
models.
So we've got to pay attention
to connectomics, anatomy,
and neurophysiology, and the
biophysical-based models end
up being known in
dynamical systems.
Let me just give
you, for those of you
who are not familiar with what
we do, a very simple example.
Imagine that you
are asked to make
a perceptual
decision-making where
you are shown a display
of random thoughts,
and your judgment is whether
the net motion of the stimulus
is, A, upward, or, B, downward.
So you can think about
a little microcircuit
where you have neuron
groups, neuron assemblies,
A or B. Within each, there is
strong recurrent excitation
between the cells, and
then, the two neural groups
compete against each other.
So what's interesting about
this type of model, I think,
is this duality.
So on one hand--
I don't know if you can--
actually, do I have a pointer?
Maybe I just use the cursor.
As you see on the
right, on one hand,
you see this very slow
transient in the form of quasi
[INAUDIBLE] ramping activity
up to a second, which
has been shown in
single neurophysiology
to underline accumulation
of information, accumulation
of evidence in favor or against
the different options, either
A or B. And, on the
other hand, there's
this also categorical
choice by winner
take all competition done
by attractive dynamics
in this model.
And the same mechanism
can sustain activity
when the stimulus
is gone, so you
can hold in working memory
your choice for later use.
And also, as I mentioned,
I'm very happy to hear,
is that one big challenge
to understand the brain
is cross-level understanding.
So this kind of model try
to move in that direction.
So in this case, starting
with recurrent dynamics,
you can ask, what's
the mechanism
underlying slow transients?
It turns out, in this case,
it's NMDAR-dependent recurrent
excitation.
So this is something you
can test using some drugs,
agonist-antagonist.
On the other hand,
you can go up,
look at psychometric
function to be
compared with
behavioral measurements
in the experiments.
So this line of research
has led to the idea
that, although the
scheme looks universal,
it could be V1
model, but somehow,
under certain conditions,
the same kind of circuit
can underlying cognitive
kind of computations,
like working memory
and decision-making.
So over the last, I don't
know, almost two decades,
we have been exploring
different kind of building
blocks of cognition.
I would say Robert
Young's work in his PhD
really kind of represents
where we are now.
So we ask the question about
how a local circuit, in PFC,
for example, can
underline so many tasks.
So that way, you can
start to ask questions
like how abstract task
representation really
is realized by neuron circuits.
One of the open questions
in this line of work
is, what is the dynamical
nature of internal states
underlying working memory
and decision-making?
I just want to make a point that
when we say attractor states,
we don't mean necessarily
steady states.
So those are two
examples where you
can have stochastic
oscillations in a network that
are attractor states.
Maybe, for physicists,
even turbulence
is actually described
as attractor state
by Navier-Stokes equation.
So those are very complex
spatial temporal patterns,
but they are attractor states.
But what is, exactly,
the nature of
spatial-temporal neural
activity patterns
that are important for internal
mental processes is not known.
So we tried to start
to think about that.
But the temporal
aspect of the sense
is really a very interesting,
still under exploited
direction.
But for the rest of
the talk, I would kind
move on to the spatial aspect
of cognitive functions,
because we now know, we
become more and more aware
that even walking
memory of simple stimuli
involves multiple brain regions.
So this is a meta
analysis figure
showing, along the axis,
different cortical areas
in macaque monkey,
how likely you
would see delay activity in
red in individual experimental
studies.
So it's not uniform
across all cortical areas.
Certain areas seem to be
engaged in working memory more
permanently than the others.
But on the other hand,
it's also distributed.
And also, Aramina,
for example, showed
that if you simultaneously
record from multiple brain
regions, in this case,
six or so cortical areas
in macaque monkey in a
simple decision task,
you also see very
distributed processes.
So it's a puzzle.
How can we understand
distributed working
memory and decision-making?
So I would say it's timely to
raise this question because
of the advances of experimental
tools and the measurements.
So I'm going to tell
you a story from my lab
where we collaborated with Henry
Kennedy, anatomist in France,
who relatively
recently published
a database of
interarea connectivity
in the macaque cortex.
So basically, I
skipped some details,
but just to tell you
that they had a way
to assess directed and
weighted connectivity
between cortical areas.
If you plot the statistics of
the weights in the upper right
panel, you would see five
orders of magnitude range
of the weight values that fit
with log normal distribution.
And also, in the
lower right panel
is shown the weight of the
connection between two areas
as a function of the distance
between the two, similar log
plot, meaning that the network
is really spatially embedding.
It depends on spatial proximity
between the areas, not
a pure topological
graph, as you would
describe with a graph theory.
So imagine that you take
this connectivity matrix
to build a dynamical model of
many interacting macaque cortex
areas.
By the way, I also
should mention
that there was a lot of
feedback projections.
About 65 of all possible
connections are present.
So it's kind of a
tense connection
at this level of
cortical-cortical connectivity.
So we did that.
So we started with this
connectivity matrix,
and the next question is, what
do you put in each local area
to build a dynamical model?
So I'm going to give
you three versions how
we went about doing that.
So the first version is to
start with this idea, very
influential idea, that there's
a canonical circuit that kind of
repeats across the
cortical mantle,
even across species in
the mammalian kingdom.
So that's saying, basically,
that all cortical areas
are the same.
What's different is
input-output patterns,
how close you are to census and
how they talk to each other.
So that definitely is true,
but it's not the only answer,
I think, because we do
also have to think about,
on the other hand, there's this
idea of modular organization.
[INAUDIBLE],, for
example, proposed that
and showed that for certain
type of information processing
for sure, right?
And also, maybe, in
the brain, there's
also some kind of modularity.
And so we try to
think about how do you
square right between on
one hand a universal kind
of canonical circuit
architecture.
On the other hand, there's
this modularity of functions.
So we are going to take
the view that, yes,
input-output patterns
are important,
but also, what's
been less emphasized
is that, in fact,
quantitatively,
there are variations from
area to area, heterogeneous,
is if you like.
So one example would
be, do genomic analysis.
You will see a lot
of gene expressions
that are different
from area to area.
So we actually started by
looking at the order database,
which is just the spine count.
As you know, spines are the
size of excitatory synapses
in pyramidal cells.
And there's only one synapse
per spine, so that's very nice.
You can think about the
number of spines per neuron
as a proxy for the strength
of excitation of a neuron.
And that turns out to change
quite a bit from area to area,
as shown in the lower left panel
as a function of hierarchy.
So actually, the
change is about 10-fold
from V1, all the way
to PFC. And so this
is one example of what we
call macroscopic gradient.
So some biological properties
that change from area to area
are not high-dimensional
heterogeneities,
but they somehow show these
gradients in low-dimensional--
along the low-dimensional axis.
So if you're interested,
you can take a look
and find out more about
especially the ones that
are important for excitation
and inhibition, which we know
are functionally important.
By this way of
thinking about it,
we actually found a way
to use genomic data, which
is still rare in
computational neuroscience.
So we're kind of
excited by that.
In a way, a big challenge is how
to relate from gene to behavior
through circuits.
So we start to think about--
and that's especially
important if you
care about psychiatric disorders
in computational psychiatry.
Just to mention
that, in my mind,
this is not only a way
to do it, but also,
a way to do it for a
large-scale system.
So, Rishi, who was a
graduate student back then,
built that dynamical
model, basically, I
explained to you using
the structure data,
and I introduced this
macroscopic gradient
for a dynamical model,
which simply means
for modelers that
you use exactly
the same mathematical equation
for each local circuit,
but then, the
strands of excitation
is scaled by a number that's
proportional to the spine
count.
That's all.
And so this is a simulation
of the resting state where
each area is driven by noise.
The network is not
doing anything.
And he found right away
that the time constant that
dominates the dynamics is
very different from area
to area, as quantified
here by autocorrelation
function of the time
series from each area,
and as shown on the lower
right, the dominant time
constant for 14 areas as
a function of hierarchy.
Notice that the range
is pretty big, from 20
milliseconds to more
than one second,
but it's not a monotonic as a
function of hierarchy, defined
by hierarchy.
So this is really a reflection
of both macroscopic gradient
of properties and this
complicated connectivity matrix
properties.
This kind of hierarchy of
time constants is really,
I think, very interesting
for a number of reasons.
To start with, you want
early sensitive areas
to be very fast in
order to process quickly
changing external stimuli.
On the other hand, when
I talk about ramping
activity underlying
accumulation of information
in decision-making, you have
very slow time constants
in the underlying circuit.
So there is now increasing
evidence from single neuron
recordings that there is indeed
a hierarchy of time constants
in monkey, shown at the top.
And those are mice just
a little bit lower left.
And by very different
measure, possibly important,
also, for human, say,
speech understanding.
You started with very
short time constants
to understand the
words, and then, you
integrate words into phrases,
from phrases to sentences,
to narratives.
And there is some evidence that
those different integrations
involve somewhat distinct
speech-related brain regions.
So the second version
of the model we did
is to incorporate
laminar structure.
That's because, as
you know, if you
want to understand
top-down versus bottom-up,
bottom up projection originates
from superficial layer,
and top-down projections
start with deep layers going
to lower areas.
And so in order to compare our
model with neurophysiology,
we focused on physiological
studies by [INAUDIBLE] others
showing, basically, that the
feedforward processing seemed
to enhance gamma
oscillation-related coherence,
whereas top-down
enhances synchrony
in alpha or low beta
frequency range.
So I'm going to skip the
details of this work,
just to show that
that actually led
us to learn a number of things.
I want to end this part just
by showing a suggested schema
from this work which could be
relevant to predict the coding.
So this is coming
derived from that study.
As you know, predic-coding
idea says that our brain is not
passive, right?
We constantly try
to infer or predict
what's going to happen
next in the environment.
So that seemed to imply
some kind of comparison
between expectation
y and the reality
x, something like x minus y.
There may be several ways of
doing that, but what we found,
a possible substrate for
this is shown at the bottom.
So basically, if the
top-down y signal,
the expectation signal
goes to the deep layer,
which projects to
the inhibitor neurons
in the superficial layer,
then change the sign
from y to minus y so that
can be compared with x.
We are starting to explore
this type of circuits
for predictive coding.
Now, so how about
working memory?
So this is my third kind of
version of the model right now.
So now, each local circuit
is a full-fledged nonlinear
multi-attractor network.
Actually, the same
model I described to you
briefly at the beginning.
Remember, I showed an
example with random dots.
It's exactly the same local
cycle model now incorporated
into each local circuit
in a large-scale system.
So again, the scheme
looks universal, so
canonical circuit idea.
And again, you have a
gradient of the strengths
of excitation and inhibition.
And now, we want
to apply this model
to distributed working memory.
And two papers just came out.
So let me just show
you one example.
In a model, what's useful
about a competition model,
I guess, is to look
at different regimes.
So this is one example when
the local recurrent connection,
even in PFC, is
not strong enough
to sustain [INAUDIBLE] activity.
So whatever you see
should be the result
of long distance connection
loops between cortical areas.
So this is a simulation of a
visual delayed response task
where you put the input of V1.
You should see that V1
MT show a strong response
during stimulus, but decays
away right away right.
Whereas LIP and frontal areas
show this sustained activity
when the input is gone.
In the lower right, you
see this activity map.
During the stimulus,
the activity
is mostly in the posterior
parts of the cortex,
but during the delay, you see
distributed working memory
that engages prefrontal
cortex, parietal cortex,
and some infratemporal areas.
If you're now just
using the same data,
plot the fire rate as a
function of the hierarchy
for all cortical areas,
then it's pretty clear
that those areas that are
engaged in working memory, that
are involved in working
memory representation
are separated from
those that are not
by a gap in the fire rate.
So if you're familiar
with dynamical systems
theory in the local
circle models,
remind you of
bifurcation diagram.
Except, now, if it
is a bifurcation,
it's something that is
new that I didn't really
find in the
mathematical literature
because we're talking about
a bifurcation in space.
X-axis is the hierarchy.
You have strongly
recurring networks.
Different areas are talking
to each other through loops.
It's not independent systems
where you change a parameter.
And that's not the case.
So you have this strong
recurring network.
So one prediction
about the bifurcation
of phase transition in
physics is this idea
that you will have
a divergence of time
constants, a so-called
critical slowing down.
And indeed, we find
that in abstract model.
and that's very interesting,
because as I showed you
in the resting state,
the time constant that
dominates dynamics should be
more or less monotonic going up
along the hierarchy.
But during the delay
period, the model predicts,
the bifurcating
space idea predicts
that you actually have this
type of pattern for the time
constant.
When you're near the
transition, the time constant,
in principle, could go to
infinity, mathematically
speaking.
And that can be tested in
single neuron recordings.
So we also found a number
of self-sustained attractor
states.
Some of them cannot be triggered
by stimulus to a sensory area,
so we don't quite understand
the functional meanings of those
attractor states.
But if you remember what I said
at the beginning, I think this,
really, potentially,
is a start to think
about all kinds of
internally driven processes
involving different
subsets of areas.
To my surprise,
certainly, the model
can account basically the
results of the meta analysis
from more than 90 monkey
physiological studies,
validating this kind
of approach, at least.
Now, let me end
with one more thing,
which is, how do you study
distributed decision-making?
So we look at
signal propagation,
which is an old problem
in computational science.
But now, you revisit it,
spike in your own version
of the model, and you give
a very brief input to the UI
and look at how
spikes propagate,
as shown on the left.
Now, what's unexpected
is the plot on the right,
especially if you look
at the peak response
as a function of the
strength of input.
For prefrontal
cortex, in red, there
seem to be some kind
of threshold in effect.
So if you are below
the threshold,
basically, you don't gain access
to PFC. There's nothing in PFC.
But if you are above it, you
will see that PFC lights up.
The system seems to
become a lot more active.
That's reminiscent of what's
called the ignition phenomena,
if you heard about it, proposed
by Stanis Dehaene and others,
the so-called global neuronal
workspace idea for awareness.
So the idea is tha--
actually, maybe I'll
show you over here.
So imagine that you just
do a detection task.
This is a monkey experiment
using a detection task
where you just change the
contrast of visual stimulus,
and below is the
psychometric function.
So if you adjust the
contrast, right in the middle,
near the threshold,
detection threshold,
now with the same physical
stimulus, sometimes you see it,
sometimes you don't see it.
In fact, there are
four types of trials.
You have hit, miss, but
also, without any stimulus,
you might have
correct rejection,
or you can have false alarm.
What they found in
this study, recording
from four different areas,
is that in V1 and V4,
neurons seem to reflect the
physical presence of stimulus
in hit and miss trials, but
in PFC, the activity pattern
is very different depending
on subjective awareness
of the stimulus.
And so the same model that I
talked to you about actually
can reproduce, essentially, the
trend across cortical areas.
We're not saying that we have
a model for consciousness,
but we have model for
distributed decision-making
now, perhaps.
Started with detection,
which perhaps is the simplest
decision process,
but we can start
to think about more and
more complex decision tasks.
Let me maybe end by
one speculative slide
about abstraction.
This is jumping
ahead, but maybe it's
appropriate for this occasion.
How we can really think
about really simple things,
gradually towards more complex,
more abstract abilities that
are uniquely human?
So perhaps we can think about
two types of abstraction.
One involves more
temporal trajectories,
like how do you organize
cooking a meal, for example,
occur in a sequence.
And the other one
is more in space.
I'm thinking about a work
like Tim Behrens and others,
how we can--
Stefano Fuizzi, right?
How do you think about
abstraction and geometric
organization of abstraction,
and maybe a combination
of those two kinds of
abstractions really
underline increasingly
more complex
and interesting
cognitive abilities.
So let me end by saying,
again, congratulations.
And I'm sure the center will
become an icon of the field.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you.
I think we will start with
some audience questions.
We have a 15 minute
Q&A, and then
I also have some prepared big
picture questions if we have
time.
There is a--
XIAO-JING WANG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You talk about
auto-correlation times
in these different
regions, and I
think that's getting at
sort of a related question
to your sort of starting
point where you've posited
that this sort of
internal life of the mind
may be generated in
these higher level areas.
Do you have data on spontaneous
patterns of activity
that are present outside
of stimuli in cortices,
like the prefrontal
cortex, that may
drive this sort of cogitation?
XIAO-JING WANG: Yeah.
I did show a slide of tests
of this hierarchy of time
constants using
single neuron data.
So people have looked at that.
But I think you have
more asking if you
put an electrode in, let's
say, humans' speech areas,
do you see this internal
integration process?
I'm sure there will
be those kind of data,
but I don't think--
I think it's a start point.
We're just starting to
get this kind of data.
There's also, just
to mention, that even
in simple working memory task--
I'm thinking about nice
work by John Murray,
articulating that,
during the delay,
there's some manipulation
of information.
Maybe you are doing some
logical computations,
converting from here
to there, and that's
internal computation.
And you could look
at time constants
in different parts of the
brain during this process.
Ann?
Ann, yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Very interesting talk.
I wonder how--
you've talked about
cortical-cortical
connectivity and spatial math
for [INAUDIBLE].
I started with a compliment.
It's a beautiful talk.
And then, you have spoken of
cortical-cortical connectivity
mainly and the kinds of maps
that one can find, either
spatial or temporal.
I just wonder, there are
so many recurrent loops
from down below the
neocortex proper.
I'm sorry to ask, but
they give every appearance
of being extremely powerful and
having some of the properties
that you've ascribed to
the neocortex itself,
including distributedness
and modularity.
XIAO-JING WANG: Yeah.
So I mentioned-- thank
you, Anne, for that point.
Definitely, of course,
subcortical structures
are important.
I mentioned that we started
using this new database
from Kennedy's group.
Of course, ideally
we hope that we
could use connectivity
data obtained
using the same
type of measurement
so it will be uniform,
high-quality data.
And to my knowledge, those data
are not quite available yet,
quantified.
I'm sure you did
a lot of anatomy.
Susan Haber, for example,
had a lot of data,
but not quite in
the same format,
same kind of quantification.
We'd love to do that.
That said, you have, indeed,
the same kind of data for mice.
So we started to
actually also build
a model for multi-regional
model of the mice brain,
including subcortical
structures.
Actually, we also
started to look
at plasticity in the models.
It's very exciting, I think.
AUDIENCE: Xiao-Jing,
yeah, great talk.
So as you know, there's been a
lot of work showing sequences
in different parts of
the brain and cortex.
Gilles Laurent just recently
had a really beautiful paper
showing long sequential
activations in intact turtle
brain.
Do you think
there's a connection
between the timescale
on which sequences
could persist in these
different hierarchical areas?
I mean, you focused on
persistent activity,
but sequences are a different
form of persistent activity.
Do you have any
thoughts on that?
XIAO-JING WANG: Not a lot.
So that definitely is a very
interesting open question
to us, especially when you think
about multi-regional systems.
Maybe just to mention that
Yuri Hanson I showed you
one plot by his work
on human speech,
he used the term
"time integration"
as if it's like a sequence
in speech, it's a sequence.
But there's no real mechanistic
kind of models, at least,
in this context.
And of course,
there are good works
on local circuits in songbirds
and in parietal cortex,
[INAUDIBLE].
So we start to think about
this, but we don't really
have clear ideas.
I mean, one
interesting question is
that you have this canonical
circuit organization,
and then, the question
is, how do you endow
and how do you explain
different areas that
may operate in different
dynamical regimes or modes?
Sequence versus oscillations,
versus some other type
of dynamical regimes.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I was hoping some
general questions, but--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
mean, maybe this
is partly a general
question, so I'll ask it.
Xiao-Jing, I have, I guess,
two general questions for you.
So one is, I guess, related
to Michael's question.
So there is this hierarchy
that you describe beautifully,
and it was really interesting
modeling work on that front.
And so I guess Michael's
question is about,
as you go up the
hierarchy, do you
see longer and longer sequences?
And an alternative
question related to that
is, is that the way that we
should think about hierarchy,
or should we think about
hierarchy as in maybe we
should expect to
see similar length
sequences or similar
types of activation
in the different areas,
but maybe they're
representing bigger and
bigger chunks of the world?
And so to the point
of your plots,
you did see an increase in
time scale as you go up,
and you showed us your
computational plots
where you get this divergence
of time scales, but divergences,
I mean, it's very fine-tuned
to get very long time skills,
but at the same time I can
think about things on seconds,
minutes, days, years, decades.
And so where are those--
that's something that's
always puzzled me.
Where are those hierarchies?
Like, where do we get
six orders of magnitude?
Do you think that's coming
from the same processes,
or do you think that
when we think cognitively
about six orders of magnitude
in time, it's something else?
XIAO-JING WANG: Yeah.
So I'd love to talk more,
offline, maybe, more, but let
me just quickly try to
answer your question.
Actually, now I think
about it, maybe just
to offer my current take,
which may a mistake,
is that if you really
think about sequence,
I want to think about
two kinds of sequences.
One is really like a play cell
kind of sequence in real time.
The other one kind
of transitions
between quasi-stable states.
That's different kind
of, I think, sequence,
perhaps more relevant
to behavior or thoughts.
Sorry.
Behavior, by that, I
mean maybe movements,
sequence of discrete
movement primitives.
So I don't know if you
think about the first time
or the second time.
So about the time
constants, it's
more relevant for
the first time.
so I mentioned the example
of predictive coding.
So for example, this
would be a really--
I think it's a good example.
So if you try to predict
when you watch a movie,
you need to know the temporal
context, what happened before.
So that's why you
need this long time
constant in high areas that has
this information about the past
to tell the downstream
system what to expect.
So that's the, I
guess, one time.
AUDIENCE: And I guess
the question I was asking
is mechanism.
Do you think we understand
mechanism for getting--
XIAO-JING WANG: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: --very
long timescales?
XIAO-JING WANG: So I
want to really say this.
Cortical [INAUDIBLE]
down does not
need any tuning of parameters.
That's especially interesting
about the [INAUDIBLE]
in space because, if you like--
it's like your parameter is
in space.
So if you change
any parameters, you
may move that location a
bit, but it's always there.
AUDIENCE: You always get
the long time scales.
Very cool.
AUDIENCE: Right.
I'll just take the
remaining two minutes
and ask a general question.
It's kind of
unusual, but can you
tell us something, maybe a
story about the human side
behind the science?
Like, we have lots of
junior people here.
Is there some difficulty that
you and people in your group
had to overcome to do
some of these sciences?
XIAO-JING WANG: Whoa.
AUDIENCE: Or maybe I can give
you a prompt, given that I--
so the first--
XIAO-JING WANG:
Actually, I don't mind.
This might be-- yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So the first
part and the second part
is pretty different, right?
So when you're starting the
research of the second part,
what are some challenges there?
Is there any challenge
finding, like, essentially
starting a new direction?
XIAO-JING WANG: Yeah,
maybe I actually
will start with the first one.
I mean, I don't
mind to tell you.
Is that what you are asking,
a bit more personal question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
XIAO-JING WANG: So how
did I get into PFC, right?
The long shot of it is that
I switched from physics
to neuroscience, as Robert
mentioned, in the lab of Walter
Freeman at UC Berkeley.
It turns out that his father was
the infamous Walter Freeman who
undertook frontal lobotomies
for thousands of people,
including the sister of
JFK, Rosemary Kennedy.
So I got to learn about the PFC
in his lab, kind of talking,
telling you about stories.
And then, probably,
I lost my job.
I couldn't find a place to go.
And I went [INAUDIBLE]
to a summer school.
That was the first time
that, of course, took place.
And that's where
I met John Renzo.
I was telling him I
don't have any place
to go after the summer school,
and he facilitated, helped me
to find a place in his group.
And I actually started to meet
with Bob, if you remember,
at NH, and I started to
talk to psychiatrists.
That's how I got into
the mystery of PFC,
very accidentally.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you, Xiao-Jing.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]